E
IS GAINING UNLIKELY ALLY.
JOINING ME NOW THE FORMER
DEMOCRAT STATE SENATE LEADER WHO
IS ENDORSING LARRY ELDER GLORIA
ROW MIRRA.
GLORIA, IT'S A HONOR TO HAVE YOU
ON THIS PROGRAM TONIGHT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Lawrence: THANK YOU.
I HAVE TO ASK YOU, WHY WAS
EDUCATION THE BREAKING POINT FOR
YOU?
>> MY MOTHER HAD A SIXTH GRADE
LEVEL OF EDUCATION.
I EARNED A PH.D. AND ULTIMATELY
CHAIRED THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
TO ME, EDUCATION IS A CIVIL
RIGHTS ISSUE.
AND ESPECIALLY IN CALIFORNIA
WITH OVER 6 MILLION CHILDREN IN
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM, I TAKE
A LOOK AT THE OUTCOMES.
AND WE FIND' 5% OF LATINO
CHILDREN CANNOT DO MATH AT GRADE
LEVEL STANDARD.
ABOUT 80% FOR AFRICAN-AMERICAN
YOUTH.
THAT WAS BEFORE THE PANDEMIC.
AND NOW THEY ARE TRYING TO TEACH
OUR YOUTH THAT 4, 2 PLUS 2
DOESN'T EVEN EQUAL 4.
TO ME I BELIEVE SCHOOL CHOICE IS
WHAT BREAKS THE CHAINS OF
POVERTY.
I FINALLY QUOTE TIRED OF WAITING
FOR GOVERNOR AFTER GOVERNOR,
LEGISLATURE, AFTER LEGISLATURE
TO DO SOMETHING RIGHT FOR
ESPECIALLY CHILDREN OF COLOR.
BUT REALLY ALL CHILDREN, ALL
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S WHY I GRAVITATED TO
SUPPORT THE RECALL AND BE A
ESPECIALLY LARRY ELDER.
>> Lawrence: YOU KNOW, SCHOOL
CHOICE BROKE THE CYCLE FOR ME
AND MY FAMILY.
BUT I HAVE GOT TO ASK YOU, WHATT
HAPPENS IF GAVIN NEWSOM REMAINS
THE GOVERNOR?
>> WELL, AGAIN, TOO, WHAT
HAPPENS IS WE'RE GOING TO SEE
SAME OLD, SAME OLD.
ESSENTIALLY, SADLY, AND I'M A
DEMOCRAT.
I HAVE PERSONALLY SEEN THE
HOSTAGE TAKING, THE POLITICAL
HOSTAGE TAKING IN SACRAMENTO.
I HAVE SEEN PERSONALLY WHETHER
IT WAS BY THE HUMONGOUS CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS THE OUTSIDE
INFLUENCE OF HOW POLICY IS
WRITTEN, BASICALLY NO BUDGET
GETS DECIDED WITHOUT THE INPUT
OF THE CTA, THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHER'S ASSOCIATION.
SO WHAT HAPPENS IS BASICALLY
IT'S LIKE GROUNDHOG DAY EXCEPT
WHEN IT COMES TO OUR SCHOOL
CHILDREN IT'S A VERY SERIOUS
NEGATIVE EFFECT.
AS A DEMOCRAT, I REALLY AM
DISAPPOINTED IN A DEMOCRATIC
PARTY THAT PURPORTS TO STAND FOR
THE RIGHTS OF MINORITIES OF
WORKING CLASS COMMUNITIES AND,
YET, IT FAILS ON THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR US
EDUCATION.
I THINK THE SCHOOLS WILL BE SHUT
DOWN AGAIN.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO SEE
THE CAPTIVE AUDIENCE THROUGH
SPECIAL INTEREST THAT RUN THE
SHOW IN SACRAMENTO.
GAVIN WILL BE FINE.
HIS KIDS WILL CONTINUE TO GO TO
THE PRIVATE SCHOOL OF HIS
CHOICE.
BUT 6 MILLION CHILDREN
OVERWHELMINGLY LATINO AND
AFRICAN-AMERICAN CHILDREN
CONDEMNED BY ZIP CODE TO FAILING
SCHOOLS.
>> Lawrence: GLORIA, YOU WERE A
LEADING DEMOCRAT.
YOU ARE STILL A DEMOCRAT.
AND I'M ALWAYS WONDERING THIS
ONE QUESTION.
BECAUSE WE SAW IT IN THE WHITE
HOUSE WHEN CDC SAID IT IS SAFE
FOR KIDS TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL.
BUT THEN THERE WAS AN EMAIL THAT
WENT OUT AND THE TEACHERS UNION
CHANGED THAT JEN PSAKI THE PRESS
SECRETARY SAID NO, ACTUALLY IT'S
NOT RIGHT.
SO WHAT HAPPENS BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS WITH THE TEACHERS UNION?
DO THEY DEMANDS OUT AND
LEGISLATORS ARE EXPECTED TO GO
ALONG WITH IT OR THEY WON'T GET
ENDORSEMENTS OR THEY WILL FUND
THEIR OPPONENTS?
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> MONEY TALKS.
AND THE POLITICIANS WALK.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT HAPPENS.
CTA IS THE MOST POWERFUL
POLITICAL FORCE IN CALIFORNIA.
IT CONTRIBUTES MORE TO A
POLITICAL WAR CHEST THAN OIL,
PHARMACEUTICALS, GAS COMBINED.
AND THESE ARE NOT YOUR EVERY DAY
TEACHERS IN A CLASSROOM.
AND WE HAVE SEEN FIGHTS THAT
HAVE GONE ALL THE WAY TO THE
SUPREME COURT TO TRY TO BREAK
FREE OF THOSE MAPPED TORE UNION
DUES THAT BASICALLY PAY FOR
CANDIDATES AND ISSUES THAT RANK
AND FILE TEACHERS DON'T SUPPORT.
IT REALLY IS THE POWER OF MONEY
THAT BASICALLY HAS BECOME A VERY
SOURED MILK IN REPRODUCING
INEQUALITY IN CALIFORNIA AND
REALLY MUCH ACROSS THE NATION AS
WELL.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS RECALL, TO
ME, WAS ABOUT A CHANCE TO BREAK
THIS SYSTEM IRFIND NO STRONGER
VOICE THAN LARRY HE WOULD HIS OR
HER ACTUALLY HAS SURVIVED THAT
AND ELOQUENT SPEAKER ON THE NEED
FOR SCHOOL CHOICE.
>> Lawrence: THANK YOU